et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec louis keumayou président du club de
l'information africaine oui bonjour et
merci d'être en direct avec nous alors
première question est ce qu'on a un peu
plus d'informations concernant les
circonstances de cette attaque d'une
violence rare on sait que trois villages
ont été attaqués par des hommes à moto
les victimes ont parfois été même égorgé
pour l'instant malheureusement non parce
que cette attaque se produit dans une
zone qui est hors de contrôle des
guérillas depuis au moins 2002 faut pas
oublier que c'est là que boko haram est
né dans les années 2002 avec un chef qui
a été tué lors des premières attaques
avaient été lancées par boko haram
et comme abubakar shekau qui est
présenté depuis quelques années comme le
nouveau chef de boko haram est de moins
en moins visibles il ne fait plus les
messages incendiaires dont il avait
l'habitude
cependant étant donné que c'est le fief
du mouvement et que le gouvernement a
encouragé les populations à entrer les
populations déplacées qu'elle
entretenait au nigeria est là et les
encourager à retourner dans leur fief à
pouvoir travailler la terre à pouvoir
voter
le mouvement a perçu cela comme un envoi
d'émissaires qu'elle est servir d'
espions pour le gouvernement et qu'ils
étaient donc là comme des ennemis pour
beaucoup c'est la seule chose dont on
dispose aujourd'hui
et l'autre chose qu'on peut ajouter
également c'est que boko haram n'opère
plus seul il ya eu des dissensions au
sein du mouvement est alors gare de
l'implantation terroriste pied dans la
région
le nord-est du nigeria est considéré
comme le pakistan de l'afrique
c'est dire à quel point le la zone est
minée par les mouvements terroristes
et justement la tête n'a toujours pas
été revendiquée tout semble indiquer que
ce sont les djihadistes de boko haram
oui tout semble le coeur parce que c'est
surtout boko haram
les mouvements qui sont nées de la
distraction au sein de beaucoup opère
plus à l'ouest
du nord du nigeria est ou pas là et la
partie au bout karam intervient parce
que cela lui permet d'aller à la fois au
niger au tchad et au cameroun dont il ya
très peu de chances que ce soit un autre
mouvement
malheureusement alors une attaque aussi
qui intervient dans un contexte
particulier puisque il y avait un vote
ce jour là les premières élections
locales depuis le début de
l'insurrection djihadiste c'est un
hasard selon vous non ce n'est pas un
hasard le fait est que boko haram a été
très instrumentalisée au nigeria à ses
débuts parce que le nord-est du gérer
cette partie là du nord du nigeria est
l'une des plus pauvres du pays et les
politiciens avaient d'abord commencé à
instrumentaliser boko haram entre
l'autorité fédérale est aujourd'hui le
monstre a dépassé ses maîtres
ce qui fait que dans des contextes
politiques dans des contextes stratégie
comme celui de cette élection
on peut revoir le montre reprendre des
forces
revivre et mettre ses menaces à
exécution
la police nigériane l'armée nigériane on
se souvient de tout les reportent tous
les reproches qui leur ont été faits par
rapport à la brutalité par rapport à la
manière dont ils maintenaient la
sécurité parfois au détriment du respect
des libertés
je pense que tout cela contribue à faire
que même dans l' attaque qui peut être
menée déjà c'est pas une attaque fédéral
c'est une attaque du de l'état du borno
les forces il n'y met pas tout l'énergie
eni mais pas toute la contribution
nécessaire
et puis il ya surtout que les mouvements
peut fuir il peut aller se réfugier dans
les pays voisins
et c'est pas toujours évident de les
attraper ou d'avoir des mouvements
d'avoir des action conjointe des pays
concernés
il ya eu une action hero dans la zone
des trois frontières entre le niger le
burkina faso et le mali il faut des
quilles à peu près la même chose en
afrique de l'ouest et en afrique
centrale puisque ça concerne le tchad le
niger et le cameroun
il faudrait qu'ils aient ce type
d'action là avec davantage de comptes de
coalition davantage d'action concerté du
droit du sud le droit de poursuite aussi
pour les forces militaires engagées
contre la butte dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme alors un attentat sanglant
perçue comme une nouvelle épreuve
l'échec du président mamadou pour paris
qui avait d'ailleurs été élu en 2015 sur
la promesse de sécuriser le nord-est du
pays comment justement à expliquer que
finalement le président nigérian n'y
arrive pas il n'est pas le seul qui n'y
arrive pas je pense que en regardant
l'évolution de la situation sur le
continent africain
non seulement il ya de plus en plus de
foyers de tension terroristes on avait
lu nigérien il ya eu le mali il ya eu la
zone du g5 sel on a également la somalie
et plus bas on a le mozambique également
tu commences est touchée également par
les airs le bénin et la côte d'ivoire
l'ont été à d'autres moments c'est
véritablement une lame de fond qui est
en train de se déployer sur le continent
et cela prouve encore une fois qu'un
pays à lui tout seul ne peut pas faire
face à la menace terroriste
on a besoin aujourd'hui d'une vraie
action à la fois dans les zones
régionales du continent africain mais de
l'union africaine également pour que
cette action soit menée de façon
concertée et que certains n'ai pas
l'impression que certains pays n'ait pas
l'impression que du fait qu'il n'y a pas
encore eu de texte sur leur terrain cela
n'arrivera pas il faut aujourd'hui que
tous les pays africains au sein de
l'union africaine considère que la
sécurité est un enjeu et quand je
continue rappelle primordial pour
l'économie du continent
c'est quand même la première économie
alors l'onu a réagi après cette attaque
a les nations unies s'inquiètent
notamment des conséquences que cet
attentat pourrait avoir sur l'insécurité
alimentaire dans la région l'année
prochaine oui parce que non seulement le
nigeria n'a plus les moyens de soutenir
des populations déplacées
mais il ne peut pas avoir les moyens
même si la zone encore une fois est
considéré comme l'une des plus pauvres
du pays
il ne peut pas se payer le luxe d'avoir
une telle pression sur son économie sans
que cela n'ait pas de conséquences
déjà ya toutes les conséquences liées à
la police 19 qui sont qui sont là et les
conséquences liés à la chute du prix du
pétrole qui n'ont pas de jouer été
compensés et l'ont tous ses effets
conjugués font que
l'état n'a plus les moyens de rentrer
toutes ses missions y compris celle
d'assurer la sécurité
mais c'est l'économie elle même qui est
impactée par toutes ces menaces
terroristes auxquels le pays fait face
et il est urgent il est plus qu urgent
aujourd'hui une réaction appropriée soit
apportée
non seulement au niveau du nigeria mais
de tout le continent africain merci
beaucoup en tout cas louis keumayou
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes président du
club de l'information africaine